il était donc très exactement 500 en
1878 garçons et filles très exactement
donc à concourir ce matin et le doyen
d'entre eux vient de fêter ses 80 ans il
se présentait à lyon ici saint-exupéry
et loire ça ferait c'est son nom a eu le
temps de potasser puisque ses deux
premiers échecs remonte à l'année 40 et
alan et 41,7 en hommage à son père qu'il
s'est lancé dans cette aventure benoît
gadret jean claude martin il était
peut-être ce matin le moins stressés des
candidats edouard ça ferait 80 cents
lycéens pour la circonstance est plutôt
à l'aise avec ses nouveaux camarades
un bon jour on se tutoie quand on est
jeune esprit vif tenues élégantes le
doyen des candidats suscite le respect
il fait pas ça comme nous pour une
situation à venir pour trouver un
travail plus tard mais fait ça pour
lui-même mais je trouve que ça c'est
digne d'un sage
bravo un sage qui malgré son expérience
a dû potasser comme les autres candidats
mais avec des cours par correspondance
c'est ici que j'ai travaillé pendant dix
mois la raison de huit heures par jour à
6 euros
edouard préfère la philosophie et
l'histoire d'où son choix pour un bac
littéraire sa hantise les épreuves
scientifiques maths physique chimie 0,6
je connais chemise qui a ajouté ça la
section elle
j'irai pas le féliciter un edouard a
raté deux fois son bac dans les années
40 ce qui n'a pas empêché sur le tard de
devenir avocat grâce à une capacité en
droit
il aurait pu en rester là mais c'était
sans compter le souvenir de ses parents
c'est rendre à mon père je disais ge
mais ma mère évidemment fait partie tout
ce qu'ils ont fait pour moi et que je
n'ai pas su reconnaître autant de
mon adolescence pour l'épreuve de philo
edwards a obtenu une heure
supplémentaire en raison de son âge
ce matin il a pris place au milieu d'un
groupe de jeunes candidates ce qui
n'était pas fait pour lui déplaire